another nuke boom
hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
in this video
we're going to be comparing the gaming
performance between the 2020 ipad pro
and the brand new galaxy tab s7 now we
already did a full comparison where we
compared the designs
the displays and basically everything
about these ipads is actually a very
long video like 20 minutes
really in depth so definitely check that
out after this one is over
but for this video we're going to be
comparing the gaming because as you guys
know
both of these have 120hz displays
but unfortunately most games actually
don't support that yet so we're going to
be playing some call of duty mobile
set to 60 and what's really nice is our
top camera right above
is the brand new sony a7 s3 which can
shoot 4k
at up to 120. we're going to be doing 60
for this video but yeah it's going to
look a lot better
than our previous gaming comparisons so
before we get into the actual gaming i
do want to mention the performance
differences
the ipad pro was able to outperform the
tab seven
and basically everything from the
processor performance
and the graphics performance as well
like almost
double the performance which is really
impressive since this thing just came
out but
let's go ahead and get into the gaming
with call of duty mobile so we're going
to start off with the ipad pro
first and this is the 11 inch model
let's go into the
graphics settings unfortunately you
can't have
max frame rate at the same time as very
high graphics quality
i'm not sure why because the performance
of this tablet is just insane
so we're just gonna do high and max and
we're gonna do some
multiplayer let's do some team
deathmatch man this display
is very
immersive it's like these guys are all
bots man this is too easy
boom so what's really nice about this
ipad compared to the
other ipads is that you get quad
stereo speakers so two of them on each
side
so it's really nice for for example
tracking footsteps
and just hearing where enemies and
gunshots gunfire
so far the experience has been really
great
perfectly smooth you can't really get a
better experience on any other ipad
use nuclear bomb sure let's do it nuke
kill all right what's my score 30 kills
zero debts that's hilarious are these
even real players like
probably all bots what's really nice
about this ipad pro is this
design where you have square edges and a
flat back it makes it really
comfortable to hold this ipad pro
especially with this
rounded corner display really really
nice
what's up bro totally hurt his footsteps
quad speakers
got him got him
got him
have i died yet i've got to say that
it's much better
with a game controller just so much
easier
compared to like holding it in your
hands you know you can actually just
set it down
nuke second match guys it's hilarious
come on boys
boom as you can see the gaming
experience is
pretty good on the ipad pro literally
just got
two nukes in a row playing against
probably all bots
so from playing on the ipad pro
everything's perfectly smooth
running very well at 60 hopefully call
of duty mobile gets 120
fps support very soon because that is
going to feel
really good 31 kills this time zero
debts
with that let's go ahead and switch to
the galaxy tab s7
so here's the tab and i'm instantly
noticing a couple of differences first
of all
it has more of a tall aspect ratio so
when you're in landscape mode it's kind
of
wider so that could be a plus or a minus
depending on what you like but i
personally like this
feels pretty good and one thing we
noticed from our full comparison was
that the
speakers on the tab s7 are much better
than the ones on the ipad pro
samsung they did a great job whoa this
is weird guys i'm getting very high
graphics quality
but i'm also getting max frame rate
we did not have that on the ipad pro
even though the ipad pro
is significantly more powerful in both
the processor and the graphics
so it's going to be interesting to see
how much better
the graphics quality is all right so far
for some reason the graphics doesn't
really look that much better to be
honest
cool got them come on bro
yeah i mean this feels great
even though we're at a higher graphics
quality
everything feels super smooth still
what's up bros
oh he got me yeah i just died
i didn't die on the ipad pro i don't
know what that means but i died on the
tab
very nice experience on this thing come
on bro
oh he's good yeah that's not a bot i'm
not really seeing that much better
graphics quality i mean still seeing
like some aliasing here
which is weird oh let me get you
yeah you got him now this is smooth guys
this
very well optimized even on this thing
with higher graphics settings
i'm pretty impressed i almost want to
say
that this feels better or more smooth
than the ipad pro
really responsive no issues at all so
far
what's up bro
got him now this feels great
i like this new design the uh squared
off
edges feel really good i like that they
chose
to go with this new design
oh you guys see that headshot that was
so bad
at least you got a head shot i've got to
say that this thing's 650 bucks compared
to 800 for the ipad pro
i mean you're really getting a lot for
your money like really great speakers
perfect performance at least in this
game running it
incredibly well 650 bucks and it comes
with the s pen
included as well but i'd say that with
the new design
this thing is excellent deal
boom all right boys
that's it you guys are done
triple kill oh come on
oh we won by two points now in our full
comparison we did notice that the ipad
pro
had better display quality in general
like deeper blacks it was less
reflective
and the colors and everything looked
better on the ipad pro
but the tab s7 it actually does have
a 7 plus model that has an amoled
display
that still has 120 hertz and that one is
gonna look
pretty nice probably better than the
ipad pro let's see
15 to six not too bad alright guys there
you go i just played some call of duty
on both of these
premium tablets and i think i'm ready to
give my
gaming conclusion first off you guys can
see both
displays are off right here i don't know
if you guys can tell from the top camera
up there but
you can tell that it has deeper blacks
on the ipad pro
compared to a more grayish display for
the tab seven but with all that said i'd
have to say that my gaming experience
was
basically very similar with both of
these they both ran the game perfectly
well but for some reason the tab s7 was
able to get
higher graphics settings and even at
those graphic settings
it played just perfectly smooth so i
guess the winner goes to the tab at 7
because
just worked perfectly smooth no issues
at all no real drop frames during game
gameplay worked
very well and as far as the design and
the premium feel
honestly the tabas 7 caught up now that
it took on
basically the same design with the
rounded edges the flat back
really nice and premium just like the
ipad pro is
now the ipad does get the advantage of
having the massive
ios app store where everything is
basically optimized
for that specific device and you're just
getting so much more games so much more
apps
so that's really nice but if you look at
it in terms of the
value for the gaming experience
honestly it has to go for the tab s7
because
you can get this for 650 bucks including
the s pen
compared to 800 not including the apple
pencil which is another 130 bucks
so with that said great gaming
experience and both of these
probably the best tablets out there but
for the dollar
the tab s7 is definitely the winner so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this gaming
comparison video between these two
tablets
and if you haven't already seen our full
comparison go ahead and watch it right
over there
and click the circle above to subscribe
because we're going to be getting in
the ipad air 4 next month and doing a
bunch
of extra comparison videos so definitely
do that
and thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
you